on va vous demander s'il vous plaît
d'ouvrir vos caméras
nous on est à Montréal
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde parlez d'opéra
avec des élèves de 6e année pourquoi pas
et puis à l'Opéra surtout si ce sont les
artistes eux-mêmes qui répondent aux
questions des jeunes voir un opéra ça
dure 2h on se dit 2h combien de temps ça
prend deux heures à composer écoute ça
peut prendre deux ans dans mon studio
avec mon piano mon crayon puis mon
papier qu'on s'arrête et on va
rencontrer les chanteurs pour voir si
toute fonctionne bien en direct de la
bibliothèque de l'école Saint-Donat à
Montréal des centaines d'élèves vivent
une classe de maître simultanément avec
le compositeur Julien Bilodeau et les
chanteuses Charlotte Gagnon et Sophie
Aubert de l'Opéra de Montréal grâce à
l'organisme l'école en réseau
173 classes réparties dans plusieurs
régions du bas du fleuve au Saguenay
vont même pouvoir apprendre à chanter
bien respirer pour vibrer à l'unisson
[Musique]
prendre du sauve ça prend le bon état
intonation de voix
ça prend du courage aussi faire ça non
là que je viens d'écouter là je pense
comme c'est magnifique c'est beau j'ai
réalisé que c'est pour te demander ah
oui moi j'aime tellement l'opéra
puis maintenant je trouve que l'opéra
c'est comme une sorte d'histoire qu'on
peut raconter à quelqu'un les
enseignants ont préparé leurs élèves
la musique populaire
ils vont décrocher assez vite et au
contraire il était debout
sauf écoute la note mais oh eh regarde
puis là il y a essayé des choses ce sont
laissés aller là-dedans puis je suis là
tout à l'heure on parlait d'aller voir
un opéra puis il dit oui oui on veut y
aller c'est un bibliothécaire scolaire
qui a eu l'idée un cherche un moyen de
de permettre à mes élèves de différents
quartiers d'entrer en contact avec toute
la richesse culturelle de Montréal
l'idée a grandi pour inclure des écoles
et des créateurs de partout au Québec le
programme de la cabane à culture
proposera donc une rencontre par mois on
va voir des créateurs dans tous les
milieux là on va avoir des danseurs on
va avoir des chanteurs du cirque on va
aussi voir des scientifiques avec
explorateur puis le jardin les jardins
de métisse les classes se connectent
peuvent participer à toutes les cabanes
découvrir plein de choses différentes
après avoir reconnu leur bibliothèque
les élèves de l'école Saint-Donat ont eu
droit à une rencontre plus que virtuelle
c'est super touchant de voir les jeunes
comme ceux qui s'intéressent parler de
l'or à la jeunesse c'est comme semer un
jardin pour demain tu sais que c'est je
trouve que le projet est extraordinaire
après de ça ce que on
a je veux vraiment aller voir un opéra
ce programme est soutenu par le
Ministère de la Culture et Bibliothèque
nationale et archives du Québec ici
Anne-Louise despaty Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]